I copied and pasted the next
view because they had a little
bit of a drawing, so I thought,
better than me
drawing it myself.
So we're on problem number 13
and I cut it off a little bit.
What is the volume of
the figure below?
Well, the volume is just
the width times the
height times the depth.
So the volume is just going to
be-- the width is x plus 4
times x plus 1 times x plus 6.
X plus 4 times x plus 1.
We can do this in our head, but
I always find it easier to
do it this way. x plus
1 times x plus 1.
1 times 4 is 4.
1 times x is x.
And then you have the x place.
x times 4 is 4x, x
times x is x squared.
Fair enough.
So that equals x squared
plus 5x plus 4.
Now, we have to multiply that
times x plus 6, right?
We did x plus 4 and x plus 1,
and this was a 6. x plus 6,
that's this side.
So now we multiply this
times x plus 6.
6 times 4 is 24.
6 times 5x is 30x.
6 times x squared
is 6x squared.
I hope you can read
what I'm writing.
Scroll down a little bit.
Now we do the x's place.
I'll do it in a different color
because I think I'm
going to run out of--
so x times 4 is 4x.
x times 5x is 5x squared.
x times x squared is
x to the third.
Have to run into
the white area.
So this is x to the third.
What's 6 plus 5?
Plus 11x squared plus
30x-- no, no, sorry.
30 plus 4 is plus 34x plus 24.
So x to the third, all of these
choices are x to the
third, plus 11x squared,
so it's either b
your d, plus 34x.
That's that one.
Plus 34x plus 24.
So the choice is b.
Next problem All right.
8a to the third plus
c to the third.
Which of these choices?
So that's interesting.
This is not a trivial thing
to just factor.
We'll have to do some
intuition here.
Well, let's think about it.
In order to have a positive
number for the a term, every
time we're multiplying, we have
to have a positive, so
this is 2a times 2a times 2a.
That would get us to
8a to the third.
But there's something
interesting about choice a,
why I already feel like
canceling out choice a.
Choice a is essentially
2a plus c to
the third power right?
Choice a is 2a plus c
to the third power.
And every time you multiply
this out, every time you
multiply 2a plus c times itself,
you're going to add
more terms. No terms are
going to cancel out.
I mean, if you were to square
this, you're going to get,
just to show you, you
get 4a squared
plus 4ac plus c squared.
And then to get the third power,
you'd multiply that
times 2a plus c.
So you're going to
get this thing.
You're actually going to get
four terms. Choice a is
definitely not the case.
In order for one of these to
simplify to this, we're going
to have to have some positives
and negatives there to cancel
out terms as you expand
these polynomials.
So let's look at the other
choices and see if
they make any sense.
2a times-- and I like looking
at the a terms and what
generates the c cubed terms and
maybe we can cancel out
some things.
2a times 4a squared, that's
8a to the third.
But minus c times c squared,
that's minus c to the the
third, right?
So I don't even have to worry
about multiplying
this whole thing out.
I know because the c cubed term
is going to come only
from this term multiplied
by this term.
There'll be other terms that
hopefully will cancel out, but
we know that choice b cannot be
the choice because minus c
times c squared is minus c to
the third, and this is a plus
right here.
So we know b can't be
the right answer.
Let's see, choice c.
I can use the same logic.
We have a minus c and
we have a plus c.
We have a plus c here.
We would have to have two plus
c's in order for this to work,
so this can't be the answer.
So just by deductive reasoning,
I can say it's
probably choice d, but I'm going
to prove it to you since
we're here to learn, not to just
answer things correctly.
So if I were to multiply those
two numbers, I have 4a squared
minus 2ac plus c squared,
and I'm multiplying that
times 2a plus c.
So I'm going to mix up all of
the terms a little bit, but
you will get the idea.
So the important thing when
you're multiplying, you could
do this in your head, is that
you multiply each of these
terms times each of those.
So c times all of that plus
this times all of of that.
So c times all of that
is c times c squared.
I'm not doing it in the right
place notation like I did last
time because it gets a little
more confusing now.
But c times c squared
is c to the third.
c times minus 2ac is
minus 2ac squared.
c times 4a squared
is 4a squared c.
And now we can do this one.
2a times c squared.
I'm going to put it in this
place because it turns into ac
squared, right? ac squared
and I have a 2.
So 2a times c squared
is 2ac squared.
2a times minus 2ac, you get a
minus 4a squared c, so it's
minus 4a squared c.
This is a plus here.
And then 2a times 4a squared
is 8a to the third.
And luckily enough, let's see,
they get 8a to the third.
This cancels out, this cancel
out, and you get
plus c to the third.
So we were right by doing our
deductive reasoning, that
choice d was the answer.
Next problem.
I've run out of space.
Let me see what the next
problem even is.
Actually, where was I?
OK, I see.
OK, problem 15.
The total area of a rectangle
is 4x to the
fourth minus 9y squared.
Which factors could represent
the length times the width?
OK, so essentially you're saying
the length times the
width is going to be equal to
the area, which is 4x to the
fourth minus 9y squared.
So to some degree, we have to
factor this into multiple
expressions.
And the first thing you should
always look at when you have
to factor any type of an
expression, especially if
there's only two terms in the
expression, does it fit the
form a squared minus
b squared?
Because if it does, you can
factor this into a plus b
times a minus b.
And if you don't trust that
these equal each other, I've
made multiple videos about it,
but just multiply them. a plus
b times a minus b is equal to
a squared minus b squared.
And luckily, this fits
that format, right?
If a squared was equal to 4x to
the fourth, then what's a?
a would be equal
to 2x squared.
And if b squared is equal to 9y
squared, then b is equal to
the square root of that,
which is 3y.
And so this definitely
is equal to a
squared minus b squared.
So this expression right here
can be factored into a plus b
times a minus b.
So a plus b is 2x squared
plus 3y times a minus b.
2x squared minus 3y.
Let's see, which
choice is that?
2x squared plus 3y?
OK, they switched the order.
Choice a says 2x squared minus
3y times 2x squared plus 3y,
which is the same thing.
You can switch orders when
you're multiplying, so the
answer is a.
Next problem, problem 16.
I'll switch colors
arbitrarily.
Problem 16: Which product of
factors is equivalent to-- let
me copy and paste this because
this is an interesting-- so
let me copy and paste
this problem.
OK, I've copied it, and now
let me paste it here.
OK, which product of factors
is equivalent to that thing
over there?
So let's simplify that.
That's my first impulse.
No, no, no, we don't even
have to simplify it.
This fits our same pattern,
right, if we can fit the
pattern a squared
minus b squared.
So look at this thing.
This has x plus 1 squared
minus y squared.
So if we said that a is equal to
x plus 1 and b is equal to
y, then we fit the pattern.
This is a squared
minus b squared.
So then this thing can just
factor into a plus b
times a minus b.
So what's a plus b?
It's x plus 1 plus y.
That's a plus b.
And then a minus b is
x plus 1 minus y.
And that is choice d.
That problem was easier than I
thought I was going to be.
Choice d, right there.
And I'm out of time again.
I'll see you in the
next video.